[Applaudissements]
comment ça va comment ça va comment ça
va je sais pas ce qui vous arrive mais
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes englo-up
de semaine en semaine
vous avez un teint aller une chemise
panthère je sais pas vous êtes qu'est-ce
qui vous arrive toi tu as juste avant
comme ça
et un peu toutes les sottises
oui parce que vous êtes un sacré
loustique si je peux me permettre et on
va commencer avec un énorme dossier que
je m'apprête à révéler au téléspectateur
Cyril si vous êtes à la maison j'imagine
que normalement vous aimez votre famille
sachez que les chroniqueurs aiment
beaucoup plus leur famille que vous voir
un peu trop en particulier Benjamin
Castaldi
Benjamin
Castaldi qui n'a aucune pitié sachez-le
pour les gens de la famille dès que vous
en boule il n'en peux plus
je le dis devant la France
des cousinades de la semaine
de la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu vois ce que c'est de dire des
conneries
[Rires]
par respect
respect pour son moule
on va pas la [__] dans la sauce
cousin toi bah oui mais ça arrive
dans la même chose les parents nous
mettent dans la même chambre etc
mais non c'est pas grave
[Rires]
on découvre
franchement personne jamais
passé aux vacances à Dunkerque
merci
on l'adore mais parfois on comprend pas
trop ce qu'elle fait alors si vous
comprenez la maison n'hésitez pas c'est
la pas comme nous de la semaine
là pas comme nous de la semaine
[Musique]
je
touche plus et les canons
j'ai plus envie de boire derrière moi
après
[Musique]
que je fais je suis comme elle moi aussi
j'ai pas envie de boire derrière moi
j'ai pas confiance
de ta bouteille ça me convient
[Rires]
ça passe c'est une question pour vous
les qualités d'un bon animateur dans le
PAF pour être voilà vraiment le King
quoi
franchement l'élocution comme Benjamin
oui le timing le timing bravo comme
gilbertez
puisque s'il y en a un qui a bien le
sens du timing Cyril c'est vous c'est le
timing de la semaine tout simplement
le timing de la semaine
[Musique]
nous avons besoin d'une assistance
et donc voilà vous avez eu c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
qui serait selon vous Cyril autour de
cette table quand vous les regardez tous
un par un dire qu'est-ce que vous dites
là comme ça première du salon
il y a de la présence oui et si il y en
a un qui vous suivrez à la vie à la mort
qui vous soutiendrait jusqu'au bout ce
serait qui parmi parmi tous ces
énergumènes Guillaume
Hugo Hugo
les historiques ceux qui sont là depuis
le début
vous êtes capable de regarder Cyril
droit dans les yeux et lui Cyril tu es
mon ami je te suivrai jusqu'au bout
alors j'ai aucune confiance en lui et
ben vous avez bien raison
[Applaudissements]
ton pote de la semaine
[Musique]
par terre
alors que va faire Jean-Michel est-ce
qu'il va soutenir chérie
[Applaudissements]
je prends le Billet pendant la pub
avec lui
vous avez dit un jour que vous pourriez
présenter animé TPMP seuls sans les
chroniqueurs j'ai dit ça oui vous avez
dit ça je me suis trompé pourtant vous
avez raison non vous avez raison parce
que pendant que vous bossez pendant que
vous êtes en train de faire le show
pendant que vous êtes en train de faire
rire la France et bien les chroniqueurs
qui sont en coulisses racontent des
immenses conneries sauf que normalement
ils sont censés un peu connaître la
téloche quoi les Microsoft
de la semaine toujours pas
les branlos de la semaine
je suis né en Italie non ça à côté de
Napoli
est-ce que tu te laisses les poils de la
table comme des moustaches chinoises
deuxième ville après Grenoble
devant la ville moi c'est toi qui
m'intéresse
parce que sinon ça te rappelle
un truc de merde
[Applaudissements]
on parlait à l'instant de vos qualités
Cyril au-delà d'avoir un très bel
épiderme et de très belle grimace et
bien quand vous parlez de gens à
l'antenne vous avez ce que vous avez
exactement le même avis hors antenne
bien sûr qu'on dit tout ça j'adore les
chéris je l'adore est-ce que vous pensez
vous êtes sur la plupart du temps la
plupart vraiment
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai appelé ça
cette séquence le pile ou face de la
semaine un connard
le pile ou face de la semaine
comme ça c'est moi
[Musique]
mais j'adore
[Applaudissements]
la personne j'aime bien parce qu'elle
fait marrer mais le truc là c'est bon
cacahuète c'est tout bon cette semaine
Cyril on a eu la chance d'avoir sur ce
plateau
sachez-le à 18h20 et son fessier 18h50
je l'adore
c'est vraiment la famille bah oui vous
l'adorez à la maison et surtout les
chroniqueurs l'ador ils étaient tous
ébahis devant une telle performance et
qui dit Afida dit autour du magnéto les
deux et on s'est concentré sur les
réactions de tous les chroniqueurs
de la semaine
donc là je suis dans le
plateaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir Bernard maintenant qui
lui est sous le choc devant une telle
prestation d'Afida
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le pire c'est bon vous êtes
complètement en duplex avec Afida
[Applaudissements]
de France
alors avant de repartir mais oui c'est
un petit bonus comme ça comme ça il y a
une autre performance sur le plateau
cette semaine à part Afida c'est une
danse endiablée de Daniel Moreau
qui fait vous l'avez vu il était choqué
sur le magnéto précédent c'est un gros
petit cochon il est très bon vous avez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu veux camarade tu es génial
oh je t'adore je t'adore tu es un fils
tu es un loup on se retrouve samedi
[Applaudissements]